[Music]
my wife
now if people want to leave our country
they can if they don't want to love our
country if they don't want to fight for
our country weekend I'll never change
[Music]
thousands of years of our country's
before hundreds women I think the extent
of horrible things that the press
doesn't cover I think we keep track
nothing yet when you look at some of the
things they said they're unthinkable if
somebody else or me or anybody else said
things like that it would be historic
but you want to look at some of the
horrible say because has never been sick
[Music]
well the Democratic Party is really
going in a direction that nobody thought
possible ago he's so far left they're
gonna fall off and flip so I think
they're making a big mistake but who
knows that stuff did that
[Music]
there's a lot of talk about the fact
that she was married to her brother I
know nothing about it I hear she's
married to her brother you're asking me
a question about it I don't know but I'm
sure that somebody would be looking at
that
[Music]
well I think the story last night was
that a hundred and eighty-seven
Republicans voted in favor of Trump and
four voted against I think that was the
big story that seems to be the story
this great unity of the Republican Party
it's very unfair what's happened with
respect to the way I would say
Republicans have being treated frankly
but certainly wait certainly the way
this president has been treated in the
history of our country has never been
anything like this and they should never
be allowed to happen to another
president again should never be allowed
to happen
despite that we've created the greatest
economy in the history of our country
we're doing things like nobody's ever
done we have the best job numbers in the
history of our country african-american
Asian American women Hispanic American
best job numbers we've ever had and I
have to go because I see it starting to
form we disagree
I'm not relishing the fight I'm enjoying
it because I have to get the word out to
the American people and you have to
enjoy what you do I enjoy what they do
the key is the key is not a question of
relishing they're wrong they're
absolutely wrong that's not where our
country wants to be we're not going to
go and we're not going to be a socialist
country it's not going to happen
[Music]